workshop we're very happy to have either
Shore from MIT give the talk and Peter
needs no introduction so let me just say
that he's going to tell us about some
very exciting recent work on building a
quantum money based on latest
assumptions okay thank you this is the
first time these slides have been used
so hopefully they don't have too many
typos in them and I want to thank the
NSF and the Army Research Office for
supporting me while doing this work and
let me start with an outline of the talk
and please don't hesitate interrupt me
at any point I'm going to start out by
giving a history and motivation for
quantum money and then some background
in terms of a few theorems about
lattices and maybe a little bit about
quantum computation we're not going to
be talking about quantum gates here
we'll be using much higher level
primitives which I will talk about I'm
not going to tell you how to build these
higher level primitives out of quantum
gates because first they're long and not
very illuminating calculations and
second it would take too long so you're
gonna have to accept the higher level
primitives I tell you I'm writing this
paper but it's not out yet and finally
let me say that I really don't have a
full grasp of the latus literature so
it's may be that some things I say can
be done much more easily some other way
and if you feel like it you can email me
afterwards and tell me about these
things ok so what is the problem with
money the problem with money is that you
can counterfeit it and suppose you want
to make the money purely digital and you
don't want any interaction well that's
absolutely impossible but quantum states
satisfy the no-cloning theorem which
says you cannot make a copy of an
unknown quantum state
so maybe you can use quantum states for
money and you might think that soil
immediately let us use wine states for
money and this was reasoner's idea
I guess his original manuscript was
somewhere around 1969 and it was first
published in 1983 because he said of to
somewhere and they rejected it and then
he sat on it for quite a while until
Charlie Bennett who was his no friend
from college
send it off to sig aku's which is a a
non refereed publication and they
published it and his scheme had
drawbacks but you know it's quite a bit
harder to come up with a quantum money
scheme that doesn't have severe projects
so people started doing this around 10
years ago and what we want to do is give
a new protocol for creating unforgeable
quantum states that is based on the
security of lattice problems ok so their
proposals for quantum money I think the
first serious one was with me and it's
based on not invariance and it has not
been broken yet but on the other hand I
have no idea how many people have tried
attacking it because the it's based on
the difficulty of a problem that have no
know that nobody has looked at seriously
as far as I know Harrison and Christiano
proposed quantum money a few years later
but it's been broken
mark janvi proposed a complexity
theoretic construction of quantum money
and I have heard that it's been broken
but I haven't seen the paper that
actually breaks it yet so I don't know
its status Daniel came last year or two
years ago now proposed something based
on modular forums and I discovered this
new scheme in November when I was
writing up an inferior scheme to send
off to stock
I discovered you could do a lot better
but of course I couldn't write a
completely new paper in one week so I
didn't send it to stock so history
this is Weiser scheme so in Weiser
scheme you put a sequence of quantum
states and one of four you know
polarizations say vertical horizontal
horizontal right diagonal left diagonal
on the bill and anybody who does not
know the polarization of these states
cannot copy them by well by the clone oh
cloning theorem in quantum mechanics and
so it's secure so what's the problem
with weiners money well the mint knows
the polarizations so the mint or whoever
produced the money can check it but you
want the merchant to be able to check it
without sending the bill back to the
mint and of course if a merchant knows
the quantization axis of eigenvalue of
some of the qubits and the merchant can
verify the money but it turns out that
if the merchant can get has enough
information to verify the money then
coalition of merchants will have enough
information to counterfeit the money so
this is the problem with Wiesner shmoney
okay so what we would like is it like
some kind of verification procedure for
some kind of quantum money that does not
allow merchants to make counterfeit
bills okay I started thinking about this
with you know ideas from cryptography so
I guess everybody here knows this
already but for many years cryptography
was done with ad-hoc crypto systems and
lots of them were eventually broken and
over the last few decades cryptography
has become much more mathematical and
hopefully we're getting better crypto
systems now and there are two kinds of
proofs of security and cryptography you
can hurt her sorry yeah there was a
question someone is asking what
what does verification mean in
I will get I will get to that so I will
I will get to that later so you can have
information li secure crypto systems and
computation will secure crypto systems
and the information we secure ones is
that no matter how terrible computer
your adversary has they will not be able
to break the crypto system because they
don't have access to enough information
and the computationally secure crypto
system says that the security of the
crypto system relies on the difficulty
of solving some computationally hard
problem so for one cryptography the BB
84 protocol for quantum key distribution
can be proven to be informational e
secure assuming only that the laws of
quantum mechanics as we know them are
correct so this solves a task which is
impossible to perform classically with
an information we secure protocol so
thus quantum money research started with
me considering the question of whether
there were any cryptographic tasks that
a quantum computer might be able to
perform with computational security and
which were completely impossible for a
digital computer to perform and we have
came up with this task
come on of money and of course after I
came up with a task I spent several
years trying to come up with a protocol
for this task but the task is that would
like one of the players in the protocol
and we will call her the mint - may be
able make a quantum state and a
verification procedure P sub I which
goes with the quantum state so these
quantum states have serial numbers on
them so that first if you apply the
procedure to the quantum state it says
yes at least with you know almost
certainly we can allow for an
exponentially small chance of failure to
the test P I does not destroy the
quantum state again will allow you to
have an exponentially small chance of
failure and three potential
counterfeiter holding both the state
part of the
money state and knowing the protocol for
verifying it cannot produce two quantum
systems possibly entangled that both
passed this test P sub I so this is what
it means to verify quantum money it's a
test that can be passed by the quantum
money but which no counter fitter can
produce two quantum systems that both
pass the test so it's really any one
thing but and it can anyone create money
I will get to that yes anyone can create
money but not I mean not not quite so in
fact in are not invariant quarter call
and in Keynes protocol based on modular
forms and their lattice protocol we
believe that not even the mint can
efficiently make another quantum state
that also passes the test piece of I so
let's see and this property is called
public key Kuan of money by Scott
Aaronson which I'm not entirely
convinced is the right name because
what's know what key is public in this
thing and mark genre is calling
something very closely related quantum
lightning because lightning never
strikes twice in the same place and our
scheme satisfies this so how do you use
unfortunates as money
well the mint makes quantum states and
it get pairs of money and surreal number
and then it publishes somewhere which
cannot be um you know tampered with this
list of valid pairs of are valid serial
numbers of the money together with the
protocol for varying buying each serial
number which is actually in this case is
very easy to compute given the serial
number and then it hands one of money
out quantum state these quantum money
states out together with I to any
customer who is willing to
I it's quantum money and now if someone
wants to create new forged quantum money
well they can do the same procedure at
the mint does and they will get a random
serial number and it won't be on this
list of serial numbers so it won't be
valid quantum money the question just as
a cryptographer so you have a different
validation procedure for each I well I
mean basically it's I mean it's a
different validation procedure but is
essentially you input I to this program
and you apply does it do the same thing
except where I comes you apply a state
dependent on I so it's actually a
different thing but it's very easy to go
from I through the validation procedure
okay so the validation procedure depends
on I in some sense it's like a normal
stuff yes okay any any other questions
so then anybody with the quantum money
who knows I and has a quantum computer
can check that it is indeed a ballad
quantum is down money state on the list
and it it passes the test piece of line
and another use for these unfortunate
eights is that you could put an
unfortunate into a ID card and then
these ID cards might be stolen but you
could not Forge them so you know that
this is valid identification of course
for actual practice for both money and
quantum ID cards you need to have
quantum states that list last longer for
than a few minutes so one possible
question is could this property be some
used quarter corner money states via
some use as a subroutine for other
quantum cryptographic protocols that
don't require such long one of those
things and I think Mark jandry has said
something about this but I'm not going
to go into it so how do
our quantum money proceeded critical
work well the outline is first we will
sketch our first candidate for quantum
lattice money and then we'll explain why
it doesn't work then we'll sketch our
next quantum right-handed aid for quite
a modest money and explain why it still
doesn't work and then we'll sketch our
current candidate and sketch the proof
that it works and we will all be doing
this a very high level so our primitives
are not going to be Wow
you know quantum gates but bigger
operations which I will tell you about
so first I need to say something about
lattices and I expect everyone at least
everyone in this workshop knows this but
I think there are probably some quantum
computation people who may not know
about lattices listening to this talk so
I'm going to go into this so a lattice
is just the set of integer combinations
of n vectors in n dimensions so it looks
something like this and the difficult
problem that I will be basing on money
on is given a basis of long vectors for
a lattice find a basis for short vectors
so these blue vectors are supposed to be
a basis for long vectors for a lattice
and these two little red doctors are
supposed to be short vectors and the
difficulty is going from the blue
vectors to the red doctors and the whole
famous algorithm for this is the
Leinster Leinster and Lovaas algorithm
which finds a basis exponentially longer
in the dimension so they mention of this
is always going to be n small n then the
shortest possible basis and I don't
think there are any algorithms today
that do better than exponentially longer
than the shortest possible basis so if
you have a lattice there are certain
things you can do with it so one of
these that we will need is bounded
distance decoding so suppose you have a
vector X that is very close to some
lattice vector
then we can find the lattice vector in
polynomial time so what does it mean
what is very close to me it means
exponentially shorter closer than the
shortest sector in class so that's
bounded distance decoding which is one
of the primitives we need to use for our
protocol another primitive is gaussian
sampling if you have a big enough ball
around some point X you can sample
lattice points in this ball with
probability proportional to a Gaussian
where the gathers you know e to the
minus the distance between the center of
the ball and the lattice point squared
over two times the standard deviation
squared and what is big enough mean it
means that Sigma the standard deviation
should be exponentially larger than the
shortest dr. in the lattice and now what
you can do with this Gaussian sampling
algorithm is you can quantum eyes it so
if Sigma is exponentially larger than
the shortest basis you can find a
superposition of lattice points and a
Gaussian ball around some given point
and quantum polynomial time and this is
the state of the superposition of
lattice points D with the amplitude on D
proportional to e to the minus D minus x
squared over 4 Sigma squared and of
course there's a normalization constant
that we won't go into but it's easy to
compute and to do this you do exactly
the same technique as Gaussian sampling
classically except you do it in quantum
okay so now there's a subclass of
lattices that I guess
Lior Eldar and i looked at and the
subclass is well first let's pretend P
is prime
actually in our papers it's not but um
it's much easier to think about it that
is Prime and everything goes through
pretty much the same way
so consider lattices and dimensions on a
P to the N cube of integers so
everything is done mod P where there's
exactly one lattice point in each fiber
column so that red line will have one
lattice point on it then they're going
to be P to the N minus one lattice
vectors in a cube and here P isn't
necessarily prime although you can
assume it is for the intuition so we
also need to define the dual of these
lattices and a dual lattice is a set of
all vectors which are perpendicular to
all vectors in a lattice and here
perpendicular will mean X dot V is a
multiple of P so this is scaled up by a
factor of P from the normal definition
of the dual lattice so this two lattice
will have one vector in each hyperplane
so there will be P lattice vectors total
and for the dual lattice here L perp
each labs dr. is a multiple of any
generating vector so the lattice vectors
are all one dimensional mod P position
so when you say when you talk about
hyper planes and earlier hyper columns
so there's a preferred direction that
depends on the lattice along which these
hyper planes and hyper columns or no any
any axes parallel hyper plane or hyper
column should have this property okay
but there's more than P of those but
it's still icy it's still the case that
there's a total of P okay yeah yeah okay
and I
want to claim for the original Alice's
if the short vector problem is hard in
arbitrary lattices it is still hard and
these lattices even if P is only
exponential in n so this is something
we've proved in our paper I think you
can probably get it from other lattice
theorems about lattices and and now we
have a quantum Fourier transform on
these lattices and this is where the
magic comes in so this quantum Fourier
transform is really only you know it's
only Delta different from the regular
quantum Fourier transform and you can
prove properties at this point Emporio
transform by using the properties as a
regular quantum Fourier transform but
it's very I mean thinking about this
quantum Fourier transform as a primitive
makes this lattice money really much
easier to understand so the quantum
Fourier transform takes a doctor in the
lattice and it takes it to a
superposition of vectors in the lattice
so the lattice a maps the lattice to
them to itself and the equation for this
transform is that X goes to
normalization e to the minus 2 pi x dot
y over P ket of Y are the quantum state
of Y so this is the Fourier transform
and you don't really need to understand
that Fourier transform here you need to
understand the properties of the Fourier
transform so I already talked about
Gaussian superposition a Gaussian
supervision of lattice points around
some point is just the superposition of
all lattice points around that point
with the amplitude decaying according to
a Gaussian and of course this Gaussian
can be you know can have a standard
deviation which is small or large and
the properties of the Gaussian Fourier
transforms as suppose you start with a
Gaussian superposition of lattice points
around of around 0 so this this first
thing is supposed to represent the
Gaussian superposition
of lattice points around the origin it
takes it to a superposition of the
Gaussian superpositions of lattice
points around each of the points of the
dual RS so to reiterate something I said
before the dual lattice is sparse
there's only peep ones in it and the
lattice has P to the N minus 1 points in
it so it's much much much denser so
there are lots of lattice points near
each point of the dual lattice and a
Gaussian superposition of lattice points
around the origin goes to a
superposition of Gaussian superpositions
of lattice points around each of the
points of the dual lattice and if the
original gaussian superb wisdom has a
large standard deviation then the
gaussian superposition is around each
point has small standard deviations and
vice versa at the original lattice point
has a small gaussian superjet has a
small standard deviation the gaussian
superstitions around each point of the
dual lattice have large standard
deviations okay and does everybody
understand this because this is really
you know the central well one of the
central things in the reason the way
that the algorithm works so are there
any questions so far okay the next
property we make inert sorry there was a
question in the Q&A which asks is the
total number of vectors over which the
superposition is remains constant yeah
because that's yes because the it's
really a supervision over all vectors
it's just a lot of them have you know
amplitudes very close to zero and the
lattice points no the superposition R is
over the lattice points and the primal
lattice in both of these
Thanks okay so so sorry Peter this is a
mesh so so the the Fourier transform
you're doing is is mod P right so it's a
it's a discrete Fourier transform yeah
the Fourier transform I'm doing is mod P
yeah because II do -2 PI x dot y over P
yeah if X times y is a multiple of P
then this is just one so I mean maybe
explicitly it's not mod P but we're just
applying it to the lattice vectors and P
to the N grid and it's you know had its
mod P yeah a quick question this is the
note I should think about the lattice is
being super dense right the primal love
is like P to the N minus 1 out of P to
the N points and the Dula this is super
sparse yes oh thanks okay and there's
and I should say that the standard
deviation of the large ball time the
standard deviation of the small balls is
equal to n over 4 pi I don't know if I
put that equation in but I should have
if I didn't
now there's another property suppose you
start not with a Gaussian ball centered
at it do a lattice point of 0 but a
different dual lattice point you still
get Gaussian balls around each to a
lattice point for the Gaussian ball
around the dual lattice dr. W has a
phase on every point in it it has the
same phase on every point in it and that
phase is e to the minus 2 pi D W over P
and
yeah I mean I'm not gonna give the
equations that prove this because you
know they take a long time to go through
and they're not particularly informative
but this is what happens so now I think
I have enough to describe this simple
algorithm okay so a simple algorithm the
quantum money state is a Gaussian
superposition of points in a small ball
around a dual lattice vector W so how do
we create it well what we're gonna do is
we're gonna start with a large Gaussian
ball centered at 0 now we take the
Fourier transform we get a lot of large
small Gaussian balls around each dual by
this point and what we're gonna do
because the original original lattice is
super dense and the dual lattice is
super sparse you can create a large
Gaussian ball with the Gaussian sampling
algorithm and now when you take the
Fourier transform you get a lot of small
Gaussian balls around each dual lattice
point and now you can use bounded
distance decoding to find the nearest do
a lattice dr. because these dual lattice
structures are very sparse so all almost
all the amplitude and this Fourier
transform which is these dual lattice
vectors small Gaussian balls around each
dual lattice point have are closer now
to the lattice point that the bounded
distance decoding will work so we get a
superposition of Gaussian balls around
each physical lattice point we can then
use the bounded distance decoding
algorithm to find the nearest lattice
point and then measure that lattice
point and that gives you a superposition
of a small Gaussian ball around a dual
lattice dr. W so this is how you create
the quantum money State and our first
algorithm which I should say does not
work but it's you know the algorithm
that does work is just you know builds
on this so you need to understand this
first so how do you verify the quantum
money state well there's a lot of things
you can do that will you know answer yes
if it is no supervision of quantum if it
if it is a su l supervision of not as
points near this in the Gaussian ball
there's a lot of things you can do which
will say yes so one thing you can do is
you can check that all the points in the
superposition are near this do a lot of
structure and that's good and now you
can do something like take the Fourier
transform and shift the lattice balls
and measure the overlap and you hope
that that you know is something that you
cannot counterfeit so there's one
possible objection to these terrific
ation tests and if we do something like
the swap test well the money will not
pass the verification test with
probability 1 which means the
verification destroys the quantum money
state so the solution to this is going
to be to use statistics to enhance the
probability of the fair activation test
so it is close to 1 and the easy way to
do that
is to make the money be many copies of
small Gaussian balls and because you
cannot create Gaussian balls at the same
lattice point more than once you will
get Gaussian balls each one centered in
a different lattice point and then you
can do statistics and see whether each
of these tests acid is passed with the
probability you expect and if is then
the whole thing will pass the
verification test with probably nearly
one and if it's not a good fund of money
state the whole thing will pass the
verification with probably close to zero
so this means that because with
statistics we're making the probability
of passing the verification test close
to one there is a standard technique in
quantum computing which says we can do
this and not destroy the original
quantum state oh I see a bunch of a
bunch of questions you know they all
have to do with the you haven't told us
what is the classical information that's
associated with the quantum money State
so oh and how that allows you to do the
verification ok so the classical
information is a dual lattice vector W
here so your quantum money state is a
Gaussian superposition and it points
around a dual lattice factor the
classical information with serial number
is a dual lattice vector so the first
thing you do when you get your quantum
money is you measure that every you know
you measure and ask is this state close
to the dual lattice vector and if it's
not a superposition of States close to
the dual lattice vector you will have a
reasonable probability of getting no to
this verification test so now you know
it's a whole bunch of states near the
small Gaussian ball or near the dual
lattice doctor and the
you want to do some other thing to make
sure it's a Gaussian small Gaussian ball
and not some other collection of states
near that do a lattice dr. and we don't
know how to do this with the slightest
money but I will tell you that later ok
so the UM and so the the BDD is solved
using just the public basis for the
lattice that parameters is the quantum
money scheme that's right
so is it Peter answer everyone's
questions
[Music]
no one speaks up we can continue thanks
Peter okay good okay so so I'm going to
tell you why you shouldn't be able to
copy first and then I'm gonna tell you
why you actually can copy so first why
should you not be able to copy this why
can you not counter to this money well
suppose you could copy it you could
sample okay let's pretend I am a
counterfeiter and I've successfully
copied the state I can sample from the
superposition of Gaussian supervision of
the original and sample from the
Gaussian superposition of a copy and
what I get are two lattice vectors which
are both close to W and now if you
subtract these two lattice vectors their
difference is close to zero and I found
a short vector in the lattice which we
know we cannot do unless you can find
arbitrarily short vectors in an
arbitrary lattice why is this well I
mean what you could do is you could take
any lattice and anybody can make a
quantum money State they won't have the
right serial number but it doesn't
matter and then if there is a algorithm
for copying States then anyone can get
an original state and a copy and if
they're both super positions of Gaussian
of super positions of vectors in the
small Gaussian ball then when they
measure it they will get two lattice
vectors which are both close to W and
their difference is close to zero and
you have a short notice doctor so that
says that you cannot copy Gaussian
superposition of lattice vectors near a
dual point at this Gaussian
superposition is not really huge so why
does
this protocol work well the reason is we
don't know how to distinguish between
having one lattice vector near this dual
lattice point W and having a Gaussian
superposition of lattice doctors near W
so what the counterfeiter could do is
just measure one lattice doctor from the
Gaussian ball and produce arbitrarily
many copies of that and because we can't
distinguish between this one doctor near
W and a Gaussian superposition this
counterfeiter has succeeded so that's
bad so we need to improve this protocol
so how do we fix this actually I think I
should stop for questions here are there
any questions
okay either everyone is understanding or
I've lost everyone so far can you go
back to the test that you did so oh but
this test it doesn't matter what this
test is because it doesn't work at all
so we don't care what this test is I'm
just the point of the slide
is that there's some probabilistic test
then you can make it deterministic by
using statistics but this test doesn't
work so I don't see why I need to talk
about it another question so just to
recap the the serial number is a doing
lattice point W right that the the state
is is a superposition of lattice points
around in a Gaussian ball around W and
this super pegasion ball is pretty small
right well it's small enough you can use
bounded distance decoding that doesn't
mean it's really small I mean it could
be no it could have a whole bunch of
lattice points and yes but but I mean to
refer it's it's exponentially the radius
is exponentially smaller than the
minimum distance of of the of the of the
dual lattice that's right but of course
P is exponentially large so you can make
this you can make this a fairly large
Gaussian ball even though it's radiuses
yeah especially small well I mean fairly
large be and relative terms at the
number of points in it okay so so how do
we
byxis protocol so what we're going to do
is we're going to use a superposition of
two copies of two Gaussian balls around
to do lattice vectors W 1 and W 2 and
we'll let L be the vector between them
and now what happens when we take the
Fourier transform well remember the
Fourier transform of small Gaussian
balls around every dual that around a
dual vector is a superposition of large
Gaussian balls around each dual vector
and these large Gaussian balls all have
different phases and what that means is
it the phases from the small Gaussian
ball around w1 interfere with the phases
of the phases when you take the Fourier
transform of the small cowskin ball
around w2 and what happens well so each
of these big balls there's the same
phase on each point and it comes from
the actual lattice point that the small
ball was around so when you add the dual
of the phases for w1 and w2 some of them
cancel each other out and some of them
and I do not have time of this talk to
go through the calculations but you can
make the probability that you see a
point with X and the earth coordinate
proportional to cos squared 2 pi X over
P and now
we can observe this interference because
this period is much larger than each of
the width of each of these large
Gaussian balls so the fact that all of
these large Gaussian balls have the same
phase or actually they not the same
phase and now the same amplitude well
that's going to shorten that's going to
squash this cosine curve down a little
bit but not by very much so you can
observe this interference on the other
hand if this interference
you know what this at this cosine was
you know had lots and lots of peaks and
valleys and it was much smaller than
each of these large Gaussian balls it
would be completely washed out by the
fact that the phase is the same or the
outlet is the same overall discussion
ball so how do we choose L so what we're
going to want is we're gonna want a
vector L in the dual lattice such that
LD is the first coordinate of thee and
remember that the
Faye's was e to the 2 pi i w1 b and e to
the 2 pi w to dot V and what that means
is because w2 is equal to W 1 plus L
because L is just difference between
these two points in the dual violence if
we choose the vector L this way we will
get exactly one cosine curve Oh thee you
know the probability of seeing a given
lattice vector is proportional to this
cosine curve and then we can actually
observe this interference and this thing
the vector L is easy to find you choose
any vector W in the dual Levis and
choose a L equals W one the first
coordinate of that W times W W inverse
times W and now L dot W is equal to W
one comes W dot W inverse times W dot W
which is just W hope one and this is mod
P I should say but you know all these
computations are mod P ok no questions
so this is the second algorithm that
still doesn't work so why doesn't it
work well it doesn't work for the same
reason but the first algorithm doesn't
work what you can do is you can find a
vector L Prime in the original lattice
that is very close to hell and in fact
that vector is L minus e1 and you can
check that L prime equals L minus you
want is orthogonal to all vectors in the
dual of s because okay right I should
have put this equation down we have L
dot V equals d1 and now L minus e1 dot B
is well the first one first thing is LD
-
um yeah l minus a 1 dot d is L dot V
minus e 1 dot d and e 1 dot d is V of 1
so this equation means that this this
data structure which is very close to
our lattice dr. L is orthogonal to all
vectors in the dual lattice and now a
counterfeiter can just choose two
vectors u 1 and u 2 which are close to W
1 and W 2 and use 1 over root 2 u 1
minus u 2 as the counterfeit-money and
of course they can find a vector that is
close to either W 1 or W 2 by measuring
this you know quantum state which is the
quantum money state it will have the
time it give you a vector close to W 1
half the time it will give you a vector
close to W 2 so half the time it gives
you u 1 and half the time you get to you
YouTube but then you think pute the
other one because you know u 1 minus u 2
is equal to L prime so this doesn't work
either and since we know u 1 and u 2 we
can make as many copies as we like so
how do we fix this well what we're going
to do is we're going to change pill and
what we're gonna do is we're going to
choose L such at LV remember we
originally chose else that LD is equal
to V of one now we're gonna choose L
such L V equals alpha times V of 1 where
alpha is going to be something close to
the radius of a small Gaussian ball and
when we find L prime well we have the
vectors L and L prime differing by an
amount comparable to the radius of a
small Gaussian ball so the average of a
sample of points cannot be at the center
of the Gaussian balls W 1 W 2 ok so this
I guess is remember L was a dual lattice
vector so L prime differs from the dual
lattice vector by the amount comparable
to the radius of a small Gaussian ball
so here is our L vector and here are
these two Gaussian balls whose
superposition is R 1 of money
now our counterfeiter is going to take L
Prime and L prime is going to be nearly
exactly L but the difference between L
Prime and L is roughly the radius of
this small Gaussian ball and now when
the counterfeiter produces these points
which differ by L prime well either the
average of these ok so again the money
is not just going to be one of these
pairs but many many many copies of these
pairs each with two different um
Gaussian small Gaussian balls differed
by L and now Wendy counterfeiter
produces these then
either the average of the left balls
will not be soldered at the duel at the
house point or the average of the right
balls will not be centered and into a
lattice point because we know that the
difference is is not exactly a dual
lattice vector but something close to it
but differing by this radius of the
small ball and that means that we can
test whether these averages are right
and if they're not we will reject the
quantum money okay so
okay so the other thing we have to do is
we have to check what happens after the
Fourier transform and now there are
alpha periods of this cosine function
and the Fourier transform where alpha
was this l dot d equals alpha the Oh
blunt alpha was the radius of the small
ball but remember P over alpha is
roughly the radius of the large Gaussian
balls if alpha is the radius of the
small Gaussian balls so now this cosine
function which is the know the
probability of actually seeing a point
in this Gaussian ball is comparable to
the width of these Gaussian balls and
that means the interference isn't washed
out completely if a period was much
smaller than the width of the Gaussian
balls then the interference would be
washed out enough that we would not be
able to observe it but since it's
since the period is roughly the same
width as the Gaussian balls the
verification still works and the
interference isn't washed out completely
any questions so far
yeah okay can you explain again why this
attack always gives you an L prime that
if I understood correctly so you have
many copies of the states so you can do
many measurements that will give you
pairs that are shifted by some time
why isn't L Prime on the average well so
you're not actually so what your what
your counterfeit money is is many pair
is 1 over 2 u 1 minus u 2 where the
difference between u 1 and u 2 is L
Prime so how do we make the counterfeit
money well I mean we we originally had
these Gaussian balls W 1 and W 2 and our
super busy are our quantum money was a
superposition of these small Gaussian
balls W 1 and W 2 actually this - should
be a plus but let's not worry about that
so so what the counter does is a measure
the superposition of W 1 and W 2 and he
either gets a u 1 which is close to W 1
or it gets a u 2 which is close to W 2
but he visit you one close to W 1 he can
find u 2 by adding L prime to it and L
prime is a vector in our lattice so if u
1 is aa lattice point close to W 1 then
u 1 plus L prime which is u 2 is a
lattice point close to W 2
so the counterfeiter measures these
super positions w1 plus w2 and then he
gets one he gets a point which is either
close to w1 are close to w2 so that's
either u1 our YouTube and then he
computes together you from whichever you
got good so there's one thing I haven't
told you about which I actually I see I
have enough time left I should have put
it in my slides but I didn't think I
would have that much time so I didn't
and that question is how do we make this
supervision do allows vectors W 1 and W
2 and the answer is that we know do
compute the state know have a state
alpha 0 plus beta alphas 1 over root 2 0
plus 1 and what we're going to do is
were into
okay so actually it's a little bit
complicated but it's a variation of a
very standard trick in quantum computing
that will let us compute a random pair
of major a random pair of Gaussian balls
with difference L even though we don't
actually have yeah yeah I know you don't
I mean I don't I can't do it without
writing down the equations and I don't
have the equations for them down but
it's a fairly standard trick in quantum
computing okay something like perhaps a
simple thing but why could I sort of
choose a w1 myself w1 and w2 myself
which differ by this kind of you know
did this sort of L and sort of you know
and why can I create the sort of the
money state by myself sort of the
question the problem is that you know
the job of the counterfeiter is to
replicate exactly the w1 and w2 that
he's given is that yeah that's the
problem the problem is the character has
to eradicate exactly the w1 and w2 is
given and he can take the mate he can
take the quantum state and he can
measure it and he get it can get a
superposition of two Gaussian balls
which differ by L yes but they will be
random
you know w1 will be random and w2 will
be w1 plus L so basically gets a front
of money state with a random serial
number and he is trying to get a quantum
money state with a serial number that is
a valid quantum money state mm-hmm
and there's an exponentially many there
are exponentially many dual points so
the chance that he actually gets the
right quantum money state is very small
Thanks
okay so I think that's the end of my
talk and it's just around right right
time to end it so that's good so what
are the challenges well one thing you
can do is I haven't done anything about
you know optimizing the time and space
required for this quantum money scheme
beyond making sure it's know all the
values are polynomial and you could try
to improve it I actually think you can
do marry a variation of Mariette Watrous
and get the Barnum the size of the
quantum money states smaller although it
will take more time to verify them maybe
but I haven't worked that out I don't
even know if it works
another thing you can do is come up with
other quantum money schemes so I mean we
have I guess I think three or four one
of money schemes that work right now
and you know there's zillions of
computationally hard problems you can
make into quicker graphic protocols you
can you know ask is there a quantum
money scheme for another cryptographic
cryptographically hard problem and you
can also ask are there other
cryptographic protocols which are
impossibly classically but which can be
done on a quantum computer okay thank
you okay so thanks Peter
I think I'm clapping so let me say that
so Shafi equal bastard active
assignments Institute and one of the
organizers of the program is going to
give us some closing remarks in just a
couple of minutes but maybe before that
we can take a few short questions if
there's more questions we'll take them
after the remarks so anyone who wants to
ask a question you can type it in the
queue
if you're an attendee you can also raise
your hand and I will unmute you so you
can ask the question so let's take a
couple of questions and then we'll hear
Shafi and then we take anymore so maybe
I'll start while everyone is thinking
about it so I had one question so I mean
in the talk you just described why a
particular attack is ruled out so within
principle I imagine in the background
you have a team that says you know so
it's two separate things to say or it's
impossible to clone the state that's one
theory and then another theorem would be
well it's impossible to prepare any
other state that also passes
verification yeah so if you want a state
to pass this verification it has to be
right if you want to state the passes
verification and has to so the question
I can read is in the attack why do we
need a different L prime to counterfeit
why can't we counterfeit with L so if
you have if you want something to pass
verification it has to be a
superposition of lattice points L is not
a difference between two lattice points
it's the difference between two dual
lattice planes so if you take one
lattice point and add L to it you don't
get a lattice point you get a random
point which will not pass purification
so if you want the verification if you
want your counterfeit money to pass
verification then it has to be a
supervision of a plus it has to be a
supervision of different lattice vectors
and if it's a superposition of different
lattice vectors there can actually only
be one lattice vector in each ball it
can only have one lattice vector near w1
and on one lattice vector near w2
because otherwise you could find a short
vector in the lattice so if you have one
lattice vector near w1 and one madison
vector your w-2 you need the difference
between them to be L prime some value
which is close to L but which isn't al
and that's how we came up with L Prime
and L prime actually works to
counterfeit the money I haven't I
haven't done I mean this this l prime
that they come up with actually has more
I mean just having an L prime close to L
is not enough to counterfeit their money
it has to have more properties but this
L prime that we came up with actually
has all the properties you need to
counterfeit the money so at that point I
almost gave up because I said well you
know things seem to be conspiring
against me to make all the quantum
lattice money breakable but then I
figured out the last step and test it
before we continue with the questions I
think maybe we will hear the closing
remarks it'll be easier so what type do
you want to say something and then we
continue with questions for them yeah
that should of us of the workshop
organiser so I just want to say on the
behalf of Mike organizer straighter and
weaker I want thank all the speakers and
of the audience so thank you very much
also a couple of administrative
announcements so we still have to let
the seminoles going on some of the talks
that were postponed from the workshop
will be moved to the lattice eminence
there's also a specially invited lecture
by Daniel E which I'm sure on lettuces
in about two weeks so all this
information you can find from the Symons
kolenda on the CMS website and finally
of the record that talks will be on
YouTube you can find a link from the
from the workshop web page and from the
same as web picture right so maybe let
me hand over to a sharpie for the
closing remarks if if she's ready if not
maybe we can mute hi everyone so I just
wanted to say again thank you all for
coming
I think it was a great workshop just a
little statistics apparently there were
three hundred sixty two unique
participants from 33 countries on the
zoom teleconference
and apparently over 2,000 additional
viewers on YouTube so I think we got a
lot more exposure than if you were to
come here in person and this is a even
without counting today today's
attendance which I think we're around
the 80s or high 70s I think it's
remarkable the resilience of this
community and the quality of the talks
I'm really grateful to everyone putting
such such a tremendous amount of work
into making things clear and accessible
by a wide audience I want to encourage
you to show up for the quantum workshop
next week I certainly will
a-although this time rather than a
expert or proclaimed expert to someone
who's really a novice and other than
that we have teas which are intended to
the program participants at 11 o'clock
right 11 or 11:30 tomorrow
I think it's 11:00 every day so which is
just a time to socialize I don't think
we're going to have it next week because
of the workshop and we didn't have it
this week but the following week and is
hoe tech came said there are seminars
there are lectures sort of for the wider
audience that are being given it's all
on Simon's webpage gonna also start some
podcasts that are related to what's
going on now some of the participants
doing work actually related to covert 19
and and other things of interest a and I
want to again say thank you to Shweta
Tuhoe tech to speak to the organizers
you know you know the nearly I'm really
humbled by how much you came together
and you know make sure make sure that
everything continues so I'm optimistic
at least about our ability to continue
doing science and goodbye okay thank you
everyone for coming
yep so stick around if you have any more
questions for Peter all right thank you
all gay bye thanks Andy
of the attendees thanks a lot to the
organizers for setting up the workshop
on short order and keeping us busy while
we're shuttering in place so thanks on
behalf of those who cannot say it orally
so okay so let's so we can continue with
questions we don't know that's one of
the advantages of this online format is
that as long as Peter has energy we can
asking questions so you know I don't
know if you had a chance to look at
those that are okay and maybe take them
in order I think one of them you
answered already and yeah okay so
there's one question how do people
authenticate the serial numbers and
agree on what serial numbers are valid
so for that well what you can do is you
can use some kind of classical
authentication protocol which is quantum
secure we don't actually have any no
clever quantum lattice way of doing that
but there are lots of ways of
authenticating things and we hope some
of them are you know quantum resistant
so we can just use any protocol for
authentication that we want so which
part of mark Chandra's quantum money is
broken I have just heard this from
someone I believe is a reliable source
that it is broken and I think that I
went back to their email I could
probably figure out which part but I I
can't tell you right now and there's one
more one more
I think the part that's broken is the
the concrete instantiation based on
polynomials yeah it's not Ernst
unchristian oh it's though it's the
lightning not the Oracle construction
either
it's it's the concrete insulation using
agreed something I think there was a
problem with that wait yeah that's what
I think that's that sounds right so I
don't understand this last question
why can't you wonder do you want to
speak on you can talk you know you can
unmute yourself yeah you have to unmute
him I I don't see how I wanna need him
okay well maybe if I go to the
participants list yes I was just
wondering because it looks like you
started with an original a superposition
and then you created the the quantum
coin by some kind of transformation the
Fourier transformation
I was just wondering like what is public
it's part is public the quantum coin
which is just the target of this
transformation or what what about where
you started from what what what is the
status of that well you start from a
superposition of Noah you start from a
Gaussian super edition of a large
Gaussian ball around the origin and
anyone can create that and then you take
the Fourier transform of that and that
gives you small quantum balls around
each dual lattice point and again anyone
can do that and now you measure a
lattice your major the closest lattice
point in the dual lattice and that gives
you the Gaussian superposition around
each to a lattice point or actually you
measure and get two Gaussian balls with
distance L between them and anyone can
do that
but you're not you're gonna get a random
pair of Gaussian balls you're not gonna
get the actual Gaussian balls that match
the serial number of the quantum money
that you're trying to counterfeit so so
there's something hidden at the
beginning so what is what is this thing
hidden which prevents me I don't get
that
Oh so so the idea what's random about
this is when you make a quantum
measurement you get a random answer and
this random answer the randomness and
your answer is your serial number so you
get a random you get a random quantum
but I cannot decide the serial number
from the beginning or something is just
like a creator it's a random process and
this will define me a serial number
that's right okay okay thanks any more
questions from those who are left here
if it's easier to ask the question by
speaking you can know with your hand and
I'll engage maybe I'll ask a little
question this is Jenny sorry yeah this
is all new to me but just to check them
and I know you're still writing the
paper do you think it's the N you would
be able rather than kind of floating out
some clever thoughts and responding to
people would say ok here is the latest
assumption here is my definition of 1/2
money here is a theorem that any
attacker breaking point to money break
the assumption or this is still beyond
reach it's too early in the game no no
if you can break the quantum money
okay let me let me let me take this back
if you can make arbitrarily many copies
of a quantum money State for this scheme
then you can find a short vector in an
arbitrary or less at least an arbitrary
lattice of this form which since you can
reduce any lattice to lattice of this
form then you can find a short vector in
an arbitrary lattice well it was also my
question is since what you took it back
right so you said so what you said is if
you can copy the money states then some
lattice assumption is broken but that's
not the same as saying if you can break
the point of money scheme well I mean
copying the lattice I mean so we know
how to okay we know how to create a lot
of states that's solid we know how to UM
verify it a lot of states and they
verify and so the the theorem is if you
can take one quantum any state that you
have the sir that you have and you know
the serial number for and turn that into
ten quantum money states that you have
and you have the serial number for then
you can find short vectors in a lattice
alright but a separate attack could be
creating ten states that are not copies
of the quantum money state but that
still succeed when you run the public
verification procedure on them know if
you can create ten copies of the quantum
money state that you that succeed when
you run the verification a seed you run
them then you can break then you can
find short vectors in a lattice and
probably the answer is if you can do it
for two then you can break short vectors
in the lattice but there's something
there's something funny about two
because we only have we have two balls
and
something might go wrong but I'm gonna
work on it and see if I can prove it or
just to definition one thing in as I
said I apologize if I'm wrong from I'm
just kind of complete Louis in the field
but at least from the papers of xandrie
I thought and as I said it's remarkable
if anything works so this is you know if
you don't achieve it it's totally fine
initially but my understanding is that
he has you know maybe ambitious but he
has a formal definition of one too many
maybe some relaxation so but definitely
when you write the paper would be really
exciting well the best-case scenario if
you just prove his definition that would
be a graphical strong definition along
the line would the mob was asking but
definite would be great if you can at
least say maybe how close you can or
exactly along the way that you said say
I'm breaking first I mean that would be
like extremely valuable not just
throughout you know some cool particular
times but to come close to get it
satisfying some definition yeah I think
I will be able to do that that would be
amazing broken it's just from our side
there at least for people who are
learning it would be great to kind of at
least appreciate the theorems before you
know seeing the techniques and just
seeing how close you can there will be
great if you can you kind of mentioned
this geographic definitions so awesome
okay great thank you so we have maybe
one last question Peter in the Q&A
asking about what specifically what kind
of luck is do you know what kind of
lattice resumption specifically on
security reduces to so the scheme I have
right now it reduces to a short vector
problem if you can find if you can break
the money you can find a vector which is
you know no no longer than some
polynomial times the short vector in the
lattice probably okay I
and tried to get that down to n but I
don't see why you couldn't get it down
to if you can break the money you can
find a vector which is no more than n
times the shortest vector in the lattice
we run as a dimension and um that is
what the security is based on right now
and I don't use any other cryptographic
assumptions okay speaker thanks a lot
Peter yeah well thank you and um I guess
you're going to post this at some point
yes so neat is going to do that it'll be
posted as a link on the workshop which
web page and it'll also be on YouTube so
if you want to link to it or some other
people you can just give the youtube
link I think this would probably take
off the tail - so next we can be out on
the workshop web page okay great thank
you okay thanks everyone